American rapper ASAP Rocky is expected
to learn by tomorrow whether Swedish
prosecutors will charge him with assault
the rapper has been detained in Sweden
for three weeks along with his cousin
and a friend
following a street walk bra last month
their case has gained worldwide
attention including from president Trump
we spoke with the families of the three
men right here in New York City who say
they just want justice can he complete I
cried nakita whispers is the cousin of
ASAP Rocky she and her husband say rocky
their son Dave and Vladimir corneal are
victims not instigators
we don't want to fight y'all video from
June 30th in Stockholm shows ASAP rocky
his cousin Dave and his friend tell two
men following them to walk away several
times but minutes later a second video
shows Rocky and the others throw one man
to the ground and punch and kick him
repeatedly that man has since been
cleared of wrongdoing you feel that they
were defending themselves yes I don't
know what else you can do to allow
someone to stop the families thanks
celebrities like Kim Kardashian west and
especially president Trump and the first
lady for advocating for their immediate
release how did that make you feel happy
for him to actually hear what they were
saying and then doing something about it
that made me feel proud Vladimir
Cornell's parents are simply asking for
their son's safe return David whispers
plans to fly to Sweden if the news goes
against his son but he and Nikita
believe the video should be enough to
clear them of any wrongdoing Nikita told
me they've called her every day so can
you imagine not owning a call that day
you know I can't imagine and the other
two guys in the video they're clear to
have everything that's what doesn't make
any sense doesn't make any sense at all
it's it's you know they it was
heartbreaking to do the interview yeah I
got towards my eyes Arabic we're all
we're all paying attention to that story